c'est un phénomène qui prend de plus en
plus d'ampleur dans certains immeubles
votre gardien pourrait bien à l'avenir
vous verbaliser
très solennelle certains concierges
peuvent donc être assermentés et dressés
des PV aux habitants c'est ma carte
d'agrément on ne garde particulière
comme quoi je suis bien assermenté des
amandes pouvant aller jusqu'à plusieurs
milliers d'euros le but de cette
démarche mieux lutter contre les
incivilités du quotidien
d'un nouveau genre affirme voir les
problèmes diminués dans leur immeuble
certains habitants voient de leur côté
ce nouveau statut d'un mauvais œil et
juste un avertissement par contre la
prochaine fois je serai dans
l'obligation de vous verbaliser vodka
c'est G2 déchets les gardiens
d'immeubles peuvent désormais mettre des
amendes est-ce une bonne chose
est-ce une bonne chose moi c'est
incroyable sans déconner tu vas être
chez toi tranquille tu vas mal sortir
tes poubelles tu vas prendre tu vas
prendre 35 balles je te le dis oui mais
je trouve ça ridicule déjà pardon mais
les infractions dont on parle elles sont
pas gravissimes on parle de mecs qui
recharge leur entretien dans les parties
communes de gens qui laissent des
cartons devant chez eux on n'est pas sur
des criminels recherchés par Interpol et
ensuite pardon mais mettre des policiers
partout je ne pense pas que ce soit la
solution pour vivre ensemble c'est quoi
la prochaine étape pour avoir des
policiers chez nous qui vont vérifier ce
que tu as bien mangé 5 fruits et légumes
par jour est-ce que tu as pris ta douche
est-ce que tu t'es lavé ça n'a aucun
sens ça n'arrive pas à devoir manger
de temps tu es assermenté quoi et ça en
deux jours de temps c'est ridicule et ça
va créer des tensions en plus avec les
gardes dans les images sur une nouvelle
série moi Walter Walker Texas concierge
des policiers oui Guillaume mais pas des
gardiens d'immeubles parce que là on est
en train de transformer la France on lui
dictature ou à chaque coin de rue chaque
bâtiment il y aura quelqu'un qui n'est
pas policier qui va juger si vous êtes
bien tiens tu as maltraité d'échelle 38
€, tu stationnes on ne sait pas bien
c'est la force de la délation et de la
milice qu'on est en train de créer il
faut faire vraiment attention et moi je
pense au gardien d'immeuble qui vont
être pris à partir parce qu'ils auront
osé mettre des PV il va être victime de
vengeance de vendetta il s'est arrêté
avec ça tout de suite Cyril alors
surtout ceux qui sont d'accord Géraldine
moi ça m'a surpris mais quand je
réfléchis en fait on n'est pas concerné
tu vis dans une maison tout seul tu vis
pas dans un logement social non mais tu
n'es pas dans un enfin là en
l'occurrence c'est Paris Habitat c'est
un bailleur social et ça réduit de 50%
les actes d'incivilité donc moi je pense
au quotidien des gens je me dis que si
les locaux de poubelles sont
dégueulasses si les parkings sont
dégueulasses s'il y a du vandalisme si
on abîme les ascenseurs et tout ça et si
les gens n'ont absolument pas le respect
du bien commun pourquoi pas moi j'ai
envie de laisser la chance à ce système
là apparemment ça marche 50% de baisse
de d'incivilité de mauvais comportement
moi je trouve que c'est très positif ça
me déranger
absolument pas voilà s'il te plaît
moi ma grand-mère était concière oui
dans le 12e toi tu es resté mais dans
l'émission
[Rires]
et je suis très et je suis très fière
d'être petite fille de concierge et ma
grand-mère elle connaissait tout
l'immeuble et et quand je vois
l'évolution de notre société moi c'est
désespérant c'est à dire elle était
respectée et elle respectait les
locataires et les propriétaires d'en
arriver à en faire des auxiliaires de
police pour que tout le monde vivent
ensemble cette dramatique mais ça c'est
avant et par ailleurs pardonne-moi par
ailleurs pardonne-moi mais j'aurais pas
voulu que ma grand-mère se mette en
danger se mettent en danger pour faire
respecter
mais mais mais mais mais voilà je je
pense qu'on met une charge on met une
charge sur les gardiens d'immeubles et
sur les concierges qui ne devraient pas
leur incomber alors Valérie moi je
voudrais dire en guise de conclusion que
c'est pas bien parce que
encore elle revient d'un marathon parce
qu'elle a mis la je disais qu'en guise
de conclusion c'est une histoire qui
peut très très mal se terminer il va y
avoir des altercations de la violence
parce que une gardienne n'est pas à
faire si c'est pas de la police ou alors
tu as pas changé tes poubelles je fais
la police et la polizza et police non
les policiers doivent rester les
policiers et rester les gardiens ça peut
se transformer en énorme bagarre ils
vont tous se retrouver au poste en garde
à vue voilà d'abord
c'est vachement excuse-moi tu crois que
tu es magnifique oui d'abord c'est sur
la base de volontariats les gardiens
bien sûr bah bien sûr ceux qui veulent
Bernard de le dire mais ils sont pas
forcés de le faire non il y a des gens
je suis désolé ils sont dégueulasse
quand tu as des gens qui sortent leur
canapé là sur le trottoir devant chez
toi bah c'est dégueulasse alors que
quand tu appelles mérite Paris je suis
désolé j'habite dans un immeuble je sais
comment ça se passe même si j'ai la
chance d'habiter dans un bon quartier ça
fait rien il y en a qui sont
dégueulasses ils te mettent le bidet
dehors ils te mettent des canapés des
sièges cassés alors que si vous donnez
un coup de fil à la mairie de Paris
c'est les gros les gros machin je sais
pas
vous mettez le numéro sur le truc
encombrant et vous le débarrasse très
vite pour les encombrants
à Paris mais pas pareil non mais qui est
des gens qui fassent des incivilités à
personne
ou des propriétaires qui font des trucs
incroyables dans les local après c'est
le concierge en fait on est d'accord
d'en arriver là c'est ça la question
il balance des trucs là je vois moi dans
mes poubelles je suis encore passé tout
à l'heure dans mes poubelles et
dans ce n'est pas bien financièrement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais il est vrai que on voit des trucs
ils sont dégueulasses il y a beaucoup de
gens qui sont dégueulasses je fais pas
une généralité mais c'est pas une
dictature ici donc tu veux parler dis-le
non oui j'ai le Verdun une question oui
je vais vous poser une question est-ce
que vous triez vos déchets arrêtez c'est
faux c'est faux c'est faux vos voisins
explique que vous ne criez pas vos
déchets
alors si vous ne triez pas vos déchets
moi j'arrive je suis gardien de votre
immeuble 38 euros d'amende très bien
vous allez les payer votre 38 euros
jamais arrêté vous allez négocier vous
allez dire la prochaine fois donc là
vous militez pour un système de
vous-même vous allez refuser la
prochaine fois je fais attention les
gardiens ne vont pas se faire payer le
premier coup il va te dire le mec t'as
quand même un bon rapport avec ton
gardien je suis désolé je suis gardien
je vous défonce il y a trois poubelles
chez nous en tout cas
la poubelle sur la tête de ma mère il y
a des Siri mais je vous fais bouffer
en flagrant en flagrant délai mais
personne
il faut avoir mis du parfum
quand Géraldine 50%, ça marche très bien
il y a que 1000 pv1100 PV quand même
distribué c'est ridicule comme échelle
d'immeuble parce que j'ai fait moi j'ai
ouvert une poubelle parce qu'il y en a
un qui a commencé à me faire chier j'ai
ouvert la poubelle pour voir son adresse
non si je l'ai je lui en foutu la
poubelle devant sa porte
tout de suite quand on déménage
je dis tout de suite
respecter les voisins comment ça
t'insulter tout ça et toi
faut mettre tout de suite
avant avant je vous le dis quand je t'ai
pas connu je faisais tout l'immeuble et
puis tu mettais un petit coup de
pression
maintenant c'est moi le chef de niveau
est-ce que tu vas faire normalement
quand on arrive l'ascenseur si tu
l'appelles je t'explique quand je suis
dans le truc je veux personne n'appelle
la soirée
ah oui ça ça fait chier quand même
intéressant
Kelly qu'est-ce que tu en penses toi moi
je compte sur la civilité des gens quand
même je trouve ça un peu je trouve ça
enfin c'est un peu délirant voilà ça
marche pas la civilité
de gendarmerie tout d'un coup de donner
une carte à tout d'un coup ta concierge
qui de temps en temps que tu vas en
weekend donner à manger à ton chat ou un
truc comme ça moi je crois qu'il vaut
mieux installer un climat de confiance
c'est de conserver plutôt que de donner
une carte c'est sûr donner une carte à
ta concierge qui tout d'un coup va te
donner des ordres au pied si couché
debout ça va être très très mal pour un
chien
[Musique]
des institutions ça veut dire qu'on
donne une carte à un mec au bout de deux
jours on lui donne une carte de police à
sermenté qui est capable alors qui c'est
l'amende tu l'as payé à qui l'amende à
qui tu es là à qui tu payes l'argent
agréé
alors donc tu as sermenté auprès de
l'état de l'autre côté
et moi j'aimerais bien voir des gardiens
dans des mais c'est une feuille totale
tu vas dire le gardien il m'aime pas lui
il m'aime pas par exemple il va me dire
je t'ai vu je t'ai vu il a raison je te
mets 135 balles j'ai maintenant je sais
pas moi je t'aime pas je te mets 135
balles il est pas sermenté et puis tu
insultes la police ça veut dire que tu
sais maintenant c'est des policiers
c'est des policiers tu penses qu'ils
sont pas des choses à faire que d'aller
dans les locaux en anglais mais c'est
comme ça chacun
dans dans des immeubles ou les mecs il
va il va faire une connerie il va lui
dire
35 balles alors à partir de maintenant
oublie ta voiture oublie ta boîte aux
lettres oublie on va faire chez ta femme
c'est impossible
de parler c'est la première faillite
mais c'est la vérité quand il vient de
la société qui vient qui te verbalisme
il ne vit pas avec toi là vous avez mis
des mecs vous leur ils vont attraper la
grosse tête ils vont se prendre pour des
chéris toute la journée
règle générale tout le monde s'entend
bien avec son gardien il y a pas de gens
qui sont
comme ça il y a des locataires ils sont
extrêmement et extrêmement je vous le
dis tumultueux euh c'est vous non non
j'en ai connu ah bah ouais moi je me
rappelle moi je suis dans un immeuble je
m'embrouillais tout le temps avec la
avec une femme là voilà qui habitait
dans l'immeuble elle était insupportable
personne ne pouvait l'avoir chaque fois
que je venais elle disait il y a des
voyous dans l'immeuble parce que
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais 135 balles
quoi
insupportable insupportable voilà mais
vous donnez vous avez donné un pouvoir à
des mecs qui vont s'inventer une vie
calme toi tu es en train de devenir
complètement folle c'est des gardiens
d'immeubles c'est pas des chéris
pas de mépris pour les gardiens
responsable j'ai eu du méprises mais
c'est la vérité je suis chauffeur
livreur je suis passé RS moi enfin on
peut avoir une conscience être gardien
et être honnête et verbalisé les gens
qui parlaient et il y a une je vous le
dis aussi sachez que à partir de dans
une semaine il y a un nouveau truc qui
tourne je sais pas si ça avait vrai ou
pas je vous dis la vérité c'est que les
boulangers ont le droit de mettre des
coups de baguette
dans la gueule il se prend assez
remonter bam tu prends une baguette dans
la tronche pourquoi les chauffeurs de
bus ils mettent pas des amandes à ceux
qui font des infractions sur la route
tu as raison et pourquoi les gars dans
les dans les auto-oneuses et bah si tu
fais un accident ils font pas un constat
exactement pourquoi on a rien n'ira pas
faire des Autobots avec des constats
exactement avec des actions et pourquoi
Johnny Depp il est pas dans le bateau
pirate
je te dis bah ouais non mais je te le
dis après c'est l'escalade des questions
qui qui te font de fous c'est triste
quand même je te le dis bah oui bah oui
voilà mais je te le dis